[Applause]
hi everybody
let me tell you something since you
since since she's done your
show uh she can't shut up about drew
barrymore that's all i hear about
that's all that's all that's the entire
topic for the house right now
i'm so relieved i feel a little less
crazy because i'm just
wild about her and i have such
admiration for both of you
thank you what a nice thing to say here
i appreciate it um fun fact
i was with steven spielberg and he had
to go
see um we had to go to westwood uh to
see a trailer for his movie
and it the footloose was playing and
like people were literally hanging from
chandeliers in the movie theater it was
like the coolest thing i've ever seen
and like people were partying in the
aisles that must feel good
yeah i remember very well that we i the
premiere
i was actually thinking about this the
other day the premiere of footloose
was in westwood and um
part way through the the premiere night
i started flipping out because it to me
it wasn't loud enough like there was a
problem with the with the with the audio
and the theater
and i thought to myself oh my god here's
this movie that's
just like so dependent on having just a
you know a bang and soundtrack just you
know knocking your heads off
and not to drop a name but i will
afterwards i was talking to quincy jones
who was actually at the
premiere and he said to me that when
your adrenaline is really flying off the
chart
that your ear automatically shuts down a
lot of uh
frequencies so it wasn't had nothing to
do with the sound system it was just
just had to do with the fact that i was
so nervous about
uh about the movie that i couldn't
actually hear it i
i love that um well your most
beautiful cool funny amazing wife i
guess i don't have to tell you
but i'm in love with her um she was on
the show
two weeks ago and she told us some fun
juicy stories would you like to see some
sure sure are you talking about my tom
cruise story
i was looking around and i was like oh
it's that little button
and he was like you press that button
and i said yeah i pressed that button
and he goes
that's the panic button and so the cops
came
they had to stop the screening i did
read that you and kevin walk around the
house naked
since you've been empty nesters is this
true because i do it too
i mean more naked than usual but like i
wouldn't say we're naked all the time
by any stretch i think you might have a
story
for us if you would share that happen
with your husband kevin bacon
it's about a bikini line wax that went
awry oh my god already i'm in
so i mean honestly i can't go into the
details but there was a moment where i
thought
i can't pull the strip off neither one
of us could figure out how to pull it
off
do we need to go to the hospital right
um what did you do when she pressed the
panic button at tom cruise's house
what's your side of that story
no i just i just i just apologize like
oh
honey
there she goes again pressing buttons
okay how about the naked around the
house now that i heard when you guys
became empty nesters
i just got excited about this story
because when my kids go to their dad's
house
um i totally walk around the house naked
in like excited rebellion that i have
the joy
to myself listen you know as long as as
long as you have
a good good curtains you know good
shades um
okay and then of course the bikini wax
story
i mean she said that you're just so
handy
that she thought that you were the go-to
man
and then it sounds like midway you were
like oh gosh
i don't know what to do uh it it made me
really
appreciate what what those trained
professionals can do
and uh it's the definition of kids don't
try this at home
kids don't try this at home when you're
naked in the house
um that must have made it all the
quicker
um okay is it true that you um bought
two goats as an anniversary present for
kira yeah
macon is one of them and louie is the
other
uh and she certainly likes
animals but i had no idea that they
would be such a big hit but she adores
the goats
i mean let's just talk about how
important
you are to all of us as an actor i mean
it's true
kevin bacon oh my goodness you have
enriched and enhanced our lives
character by character and now sitting
on a hill
um your character jackie can be
immoral and even you know a little slimy
and yet you are
totally rooting for him how do you pull
that off
as an actor because that is so difficult
to do
all i try to do is stay true to
who i think this person is and
um and just turn him into a human being
because jackie has
so many terrible qualities but he's not
a monster
he's an actual human being and that's
that's the thing that i just try to
focus on
well your performance is so exceptional
in this and that dance is so hard to
pull off and yet you do
[Music]